you can just say I'm rebellious I don't
care I'm gonna do whatever I want to do
I'm gonna live my life and I'm gonna
have fun I'll tell you what living your
life and having fun is gonna lead you to
today the people that seem like they
having the greatest time having all the
fun is these entertainers these
bling-bling people like Britney Spears
like Destiny's Child your sister no
one's talking about these little
bling-bling [ __ ] now she wasn't a
bling-bling [ __ ] but she started out
she was a little girl with blonde hair
hopped around and skip around she was a
she was at that time innocent her mother
and father was letting her dance and
singing you know she got on the radio
and the TV and she got some awards and
she was still a virgin at 13 but by 15
she was a prostitute and now she's 19
she's 20 and she had prostitute herself
in about 19 different countries 19 years
old can you imagine a young girl started
out innocent at 13 years old and she is
the hero she is the model she is that
she is the poster child for all of these
women and she's nothing but a
bling-bling Hall and all these other
bling bling criminals that our sons and
daughters are wearing their shirts
wearing their coats wearing their
jackets wearing their hats Eminem 50
cent wearing they're wearing their
although their shirts these are heroes
putting up their posters what are they
they're bling-bling criminals don't sell
us fornicators liars dealers cursing God
cussing their parents
killing people selling drugs and these
become our heroes these movies that they
become movie stars they become
television stars hip-hop they call them
new generation hip-hop they are going to
be hippin and hoppin they're going to be
hipping and happen they're going to be
snap crackle and pop in in the Hellfire
yes they will be hipping and happy
[Music]
because that is the final consequence
for corruption a loss panel Dallas it in
the Quran hell design is there any other
reward for good other than good if you
don't do good how do you think expect
good so as a result Allah subhanAllah
Allah have shown us that all of these
people who seem to be having fun who
have become the heroes the television
the movie stars the poster stars the
magazine stars looking like they are
happy and proud and big homes and big
money so far they are the most miserable
people they die early they are diseased
they live with despair they wind up
lonely and living in dark places they
are the most frustrated people and when
they die they have no legacy whatsoever
why because everything that the creator
told us not to do when we do it it winds
up with disease you name it
if the Creator told us not to drink
alcohol what is one of the greatest
diseases in the world today
if the Creator told us not to use drugs
what is one of the greatest diseases in
the world today the Creator told us not
to fornicate not to commit adultery what
is the greatest disease in the world
today sexually transmitted diseases its
creator told us to be fair
don't take interest what is the greatest
source of stress in the world today dead
everything the creator said don't do if
you do it because you have the will to
do it
it ends up with disease everything the
creator said to do if you do it it winds
up as a gift it winds up as a refinement
it right winds up as an acquired habit
it winds up as something that you can
leave as a legacy
if the creator's said do good actions a
person that tells the truth he builds
around them and insulates around
themselves children society corporation
business government that is built upon
truth truth only leads to truth lies
only need to lies when the Creator said
to us perform worship recognize pay
tribute complete the terms when you see
that a person is driven by faith when
you see that a person's life falls
within the parameters of faith a
person's conscience is driven by faith
when a person it brings about honor it
brings about integrity it brings about
strength support reputation today as a
result of the fact that creator has said
to us respect each other we have no more
family values and what is the loss of
family values led to again disease I'm
saying to you that you have a personal
responsibility your personal
responsibility is to make the choice to
bear witness to accept to declare to put
yourself on a path where you recognize
your Creator and secondly not only that
you recognize your Creator but that
you're willing to make some kind of
tribute towards your Creator by either
praising or by following or adhering and
finally you have a choice
you have a responsibility to not only
accept and to recognize but to conform
conform means submit
[Music]
[Music]
you